right Melvin Gordon believes he doesn't
belong with the charters any longer not
because he can't play but because he
wants out because they won't pay him it
was reported yesterday and more
specifically Gordon's agent went on the
record with Josie Anderson of ESPN to
say that last week Borden asked to be
traded the Chargers said they still
consider Gordon family and they did not
give Gordon permission to seek a trade
on his own the practical impact that was
putting this out there
it lets every other team know hey if
you're interested give the charges a
call of course they probably already had
an idea that Gordon may be available
given the fact that he's held out but
big cat here's my issue with this and we
haven't had a chance to talk about any
of these holdouts yet there's still four
guys who are staying out of camp even
though they currently have a contract
with Melvin Gordon I think he's over
playing his hand I don't think he's a
truly special running back I don't think
the Chargers gonna pay him and good luck
finding another team that will pay
Gordon what he wants and give the
Chargers whatever they would want by way
of a trade I don't think there's a team
out there that would do it yeah I agree
with you and we are gonna get to all the
holdouts in the next segment and and I
have some thoughts about the the shift
in the league and the power going more
to the players starting with Khalil Mack
last year but you were right on Melvin
Gordon he is the one case where you have
the double whammy he has the running
back position where most teams are
saying you know what let's not pay the
running backs let's keep going back to
the draft for young guys we should pay
everyone else on our team but when we're
throwing on first down and you know
we're throwing 75% of the time why are
we paying a running back who can
probably give us 75% of Melvin Gordon's
output for a lot cheaper
the Chargers also what for know without
Melvin Gordon last year small sample
size but it shows you how the running
back position has changed over history
and then on top of that there's a better
running back who's doing the same thing
as him right now and I think that hurts
this case even more the fact that his
ecology is holding out in Dallas and
you're sitting there and in San Diego
say oh sorry LA I always say San Diego
I'm still gonna say San Diego you're
sitting there in LA with the Chargers
and you're trying to say I deserve
premier running back money
well the Chargers
first of all shouldn't give you the
money and second of all they probably
shouldn't do anything until a Zika
Elliot gets figured out and then give
them less if they want to give him
anything
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports